optimism and excitement yet I know many
of you look ahead to 2023 with
apprehension
I want you to know that as your prime
minister I will work night and day to
change that and quickly
not just by providing relief and peace
of mind for the months to come although
we will
but also by changing our country and
building a better future for our
children and grandchildren
a future that restores optimism hope and
pride in Britain
let me first address two issues that I
know at the Forefront of everyone's
Minds
I know there are challenges in a e
people are understandably anxious when
they see ambulances queuing outside
hospitals
you should know we're taking urgent
action
increasing bed capacity by seven
thousand more hospital beds and more
people cared at home
providing new funding to discharge
people into social care in the community
freeing up beds and the NHS are working
urgently on future plans for a e and
ambulances
and on strikes
there's a lot of misinformation out
there
so I want people to clearly understand
the government's position
we hugely value public sector workers
like nurses
they do incredibly important work
and that's why we want a reasonable
dialogue with the unions about what's
responsible and fair for our country
and in the coming days we will update
you on the government's next steps
today
I want to make a simple commitment
this government will always reflect the
people's priorities
people don't want politicians who
promise the Earth and then fail to
deliver
they want government to focus Less on
politics and more on the things they
care about
the cost of living too high waiting
times in the NHS
too long
illegal migration
far too much
I think people do accept that many of
these challenges are at least in part
the legacy of covid and impacted by the
war in Ukraine
but that's not an excuse
we need to address these problems not
just talk about them
and since I became prime minister we've
made progress
stabilize the economy and people's
mortgage rates provided 26 billion
pounds of support for the cost of living
invested billions more in schools the
NHS and social care
deepened ties with allies around the
world on everything from Ukraine to our
Collective Economic Security
continued our unwavering support for the
armed forces in their efforts to keep us
safe
and set out a concrete plan to stop the
boats and tackle the unfairness of
illegal migration
but of course we need to do more
so I want to make five promises to you
today
five pledges to deliver peace of mind
five foundations on which to build a
better future for our children and
grandchildren
first
we will halve inflation this year to
ease the cost of living and give people
Financial Security
second
we will grow the economy creating better
paid jobs and opportunity right across
the country
third
we will make sure our national debt is
falling so that we can secure the future
of Public Services
fourth
NHS waiting lists will fall and people
will get the care they need more quickly
fifth
we will pass new laws to stop small
boats making sure that if you come to
this country illegally you are detained
and swiftly removed
so
five promises
we will halve inflation grow the economy
reduce debt cut waiting lists and stop
the boats those are the people's
priorities they are your government's
priorities and we will either have
achieved them or not no tricks no
ambiguity
we're either delivering for you or we're
not
we will rebuild trust in politics
through action or not at all
so I ask you to judge us on the effort
that we put in and the results that we
achieve
now these five promises are the people's
priorities
so they're my immediate priorities too
but they're not the limit of my
ambitions for our country they're the
foundation
my aim is to build a better future for
our children and grandchildren a future
where they feel optimism hope and pride
and to realize that Vision we need to
change our mindset
now politicians talk a lot about change
but the truth is no government no prime
minister can change a country by force
of will or dictat alone
real change isn't provided it's created
it's not given it's demanded not granted
but invented
the choices we make as individuals as
workers business owners parents all add
up to something far greater
and if we're honest
change also requires sacrifice
and hard work
it's a big risk for a politician to say
that but the stakes are too high and the
rewards too great not to level with you
so change is hard
it takes time
but it is possible
and we know that because we've done it
before during covid we protected
millions of people's jobs and businesses
a record I'm proud of
and we know it's possible
because you can see change happening you
can feel it just look at our state
scores empowered by reform in some of
the most deprived parts of the country
producing some of the best results
those teachers and pupils work hard and
make sacrifices because they know that
what they are doing is bigger than
themselves
they demand Inspire and deliver
excellence
and their ethos of Excellence can become
the animating Spirit of our nation
inspired by them together we can change
our country's character we can reverse
the creeping acceptance of a narrative
of decline reject pessimism and fatalism
refuse limits on our aspirations and to
do that we need to have the imagination
and confidence to do things differently
and better
the vision to do today what is needed
for tomorrow
in other words we need to change the way
our country works that requires a change
in mindset
what does that mean in practice it means
a more Innovative economy so stronger
communities and safer streets a
world-class education system an NHS
built around patients and a society that
truly values the family
in all these areas and more we must have
the courage to change to think bigger
strive for excellence not give up when
things get tough
and if we can do that
then we really can build a better future
in the coming months I will set out our
plans in each of these areas but let me
set the direction today
a better future is one where our economy
is growing faster so that everybody
everywhere across our Union has new
opportunities for better paying good
jobs
and the change we need is to put
Innovation at the heart of everything we
do
an ethos embodied by so many of the
Fantastic businesses right here at
plexel
now some people think Innovation is
about gadgets and geekery are nice to
have peripheral to growth compared to
the traditional levers of tax and spend
but that is exactly the mindset that we
need to change
let me tell you why Innovation is so
important over the last 50 years it was
responsible for around half of the UK's
productivity increase
new jobs are created by Innovation
people's wages increased by Innovation
the cost of goods and services reduced
by Innovation and major challenges like
energy security and Net Zero will be
solved by Innovation the more we
innovate the more we grow
and the world is seeing an incredible
wave of scientific and technological
change so right now the most powerful
way to achieve higher growth is to make
sure the UK is the most Innovative
economy in the world
and that's why we're increasing Public
Funding in r d to 20 billion pounds to
enhance our world-leading strengths in
AI Life Sciences Quantum fintech and
Green Technology
seizing the opportunities of brexit to
ensure our regulatory system is agile
and pro-innovation making sure
entrepreneurial and fast-growing
companies get the finance they need to
expand
spreading a culture of creative thinking
and doing things differently across
every part of the UK
if we're going to deliver this better
future
people will have to work hard
but I believe
good well-paid jobs
are about more than just Financial
Security
they give people purpose confidence
dignity
the chance to build a better life from
themselves
but I also believe that if you work hard
and play by the rules you should be
rewarded
and which is why as soon as we can the
government will reduce the burden of
Taxation on working people
and it is staggering that at a time when
businesses are crying out for workers a
quarter of our labor force is inactive
so our growth plan will look at how we
can support those who can to move back
into work including through the welfare
system
now all of this will make this country a
beacon of science technology and
Enterprise and lift our productivity
raise our growth rate and create jobs in
the decades to come
good jobs give people pride in their own
lives
but a better future also means
reinforcing people's pride in the places
they call home
and the change we need
is to do away with the idea that it's
inevitable that some communities in some
places can never and will never get
better
I love my local community and it's not
right that too many for far too long
have not felt that same sense of meaning
and belonging
a government can't create it it's
something that we build together
but the state does provide the
foundations
so we will deliver on our promise to
level up with greater investment in
local areas to boost growth create jobs
and reinvigorate our high streets and
town centers
but all the Regeneration in the world
won't mean anything
unless people feel safe in their
communities
so by this spring we'll have an extra 20
000 police officers patrolling the
streets answering the call for help and
catching criminals
we've got to stop violence against women
and girls
and let's be frank that means men taking
responsibility for creating a culture
and Society where women are safe in
their communities and at home
we've got to reduce reoffending because
a small number of career criminals
account for disproportionate amounts of
crime and we've got to beat addiction
because heroin and crack addicts account
for almost half of all robberies
strong communities are also built on
values
on the Golden Rule treat others as you
would like to be treated yourself
but too often a small minority break
that Golden Rule
they spray graffiti on war memorials
discard needles and nitrous oxide
canisters in children's playgrounds
gang together and cause disorder and
disruption
anti-social behavior isn't inevitable or
a minor crime
it makes life miserable for so many
and it can be a gateway to more extreme
crimes so this government will work
tirelessly to crack down on anti-social
Behavior giving police forces Mayors and
local authorities the tools they need
and giving communities confidence that
these crimes will be quickly and visibly
punished
wherever you live
in our United Kingdom you should be able
to feel proud of your community and
that's what will work together to
achieve
so we will create a better future by
changing our economy and strengthening
our communities
we also
need greater social justice
and the way we achieve that is education
this is personal for me every
opportunity I've had in life began with
the education I was so fortunate to
receive
and it's a single most important reason
why I came into politics
to give every child the highest possible
standard of Education
thanks to the reforms we've introduced
since 2010 and the hard work of so many
excellent teachers we've made incredible
progress
but with the right plan
the right commitment to Excellence
I cannot see any reason
why we can't rival the best education
systems in the world
to do that yes we'll need to fix the
damage of covid especially for our
youngest pupils and yes it will require
more investment
which is why just a few weeks ago in the
Autumn statement we provided two billion
pounds of extra funding for schools
but that's not the limit of our
Ambitions we're not content with just
catching up
first we need to support good teaching
and spread best practice with a plan to
improve attainment in primary schools
next
we need to stop seeing education as
something that ends age 18 or that sees
University as the only option with more
technical education lifelong learning
and apprenticeships
and one of the biggest challenges in
mindset we need an education today is to
reimagine our approach to numeracy
as Chancellor I introduce multiply a new
program to give hundreds of thousands of
adults the opportunity to get the basic
numerical skills they need
but we're one of the few countries
not to require our children to study
some form of maths up to the age of 18.
right now
just half of all 16 to 19 year olds
study any maths at all
yet in a world where data is everywhere
and statistics underpin every job
letting our children out into that world
without those skills is letting our
children down
so we need to go further
I am now making numeracy a central
objective of our education system
now that doesn't have to mean a
compulsory a level of math for everyone
but we will work with the sector to move
towards all children studying some form
of maths to 18.
just imagine what greater numeracy will
unlock for people
skills to feel confidence with your
finances to find the best mortgage deal
or savings rate
the ability to do your job better and
get paid more and greater
self-confidence to navigate a changing
world
improving education
is the closest thing to a silver bullet
there is
the best Economic Policy the best social
policy the best moral policy and that's
why it's this government's policy
as we build this better future for our
children and grandchildren I feel a deep
responsibility to pass on a Health
Service that will be there for them just
as it was for our parents and
grandparents
when I talk about the NHS I'm not just
talking about a prize Public Service I'm
talking about my family's life calling
my dad was a doctor
I grew up working in my mum's Pharmacy I
saw day in day out the devotion they
gave to their patients
and my record demonstrates how important
those memories are to me
we've significantly increased funding
for Health and Social care recruited
thousands more doctors and nurses
upgraded more hospitals with
cutting-edge technology
but covid has imposed massive new
pressures and people are waiting too
long for the care they need
and we're fixing that but we need to do
more
at a time when we're putting record sums
into the NHS and recruiting record
numbers of doctors and nurses
Healthcare professionals are still
unable to deliver the care they want and
patients aren't receiving the care they
deserve
so we need to recognize
that something has to change
now it doesn't mean structural reforms
to the NHS we will always protect the
founding principles of an NHS free at
the point of use
but what it does mean
is an NHS where patients are in control
with as much Choice as possible
where we're comfortable with the NHS
using more independent capacity if
that's what it takes to get patients
quicker and better care where patients
can access more information and data
allowing them to make more informed
choices and hold services to account
and where we will no longer accept
unwarranted variation in performance
between trusts because high quality
Healthcare should be there for you
wherever you live
and as the NHS works with professions to
develop a Workforce strategy early this
year
I've asked them to consider how we can
best support doctors nurses and other
Healthcare professionals like
pharmacists to work more flexibly
we all share the same objective when it
comes to the NHS to continue providing
high quality responsive health care for
generations to come and that's what
we're going to deliver
our vision for change will Revitalize
every aspect of Our Lives better jobs
stronger communities world-class
education and NHS built around patients
but family
is something politicians struggle to
talk about
because you can all too readily be
pilloried for being out of touch or
Worse hostile
to those who don't conform to some
idealized form
we live in a world today where family
can and does take many forms
but whatever your family looks like it
doesn't matter as long as the common
bond is love
we shouldn't be shy about it
we cannot not talk about the thing that
is most important in most of our lives
not when the evidence is clear that
strong supportive families make for more
stable communities and happier
individuals
I wouldn't be where I am today without
the love of my family the kindness they
gave me the sacrifices they made for me
the values they taught me
I learned from them the virtues of hard
work and self-improvement
the importance of treating others with
respect the value of service of how a
community relies on people going above
and beyond what they are required to do
today it is the love of my wife and
children that sustains me in the most
difficult moments in this job
Family Matters
we need to support parents to manage the
demands of modern workplaces without
weakening the Irreplaceable bonds of
family life
and we're going to roll out family hubs
to offer parents the support they need
to raise a child
because I believe deeply that family not
just government can help us answer the
profound questions we face as a country
when it comes to health family cares for
us when we were sick and old family
teaches us values in education
when it comes to Community Family guides
Us in right and wrong
that's why family runs right through our
vision of a better future
when I first spoke to you as prime
minister
I stress the trust
was not given but earned
I hope that in these first few weeks in
the job I have begun to earn your trust
and I've made five promises today to
deliver peace of mind
we will halve inflation grow the economy
reduce debt cut waiting times and stop
the boats
but I know this is just a start
of what we need to do to build a better
Britain together
as well as peace of mind today this
afternoon I've also set out a vision for
a better future for our children and
grandchildren
now we're not going to get there
overnight or even in this Parliament
that this is the journey we are on
and despite all the challenges we face
all the anxieties that people feel I
know we can get there
Others May talk about change I will
deliver it I won't offer you false hope
or quick fixes that meaningful lasting
change
I want people to feel something that
they do not always feel today a belief
that public services work for them a
knowledge that if you work hard in the
good times the state will be there for
you during the bad a hope that the world
will be better for their children than
it was for them a sense of belonging in
the place they call home
I guarantee that your priorities will be
my priorities I pledge that I will be
honest about the challenges we face and
I will take the tough but necessary
decisions to ensure our great country
achieves its enormous potential
I will only promise what I can deliver
and I will deliver
what I promise
thank you
foreign
thank you
right I think we've got a good amount of
time to take some questions from the
media I want to like kick off Chris
Mason from the BBC
prime minister thank you Chris Mason BBC
News
um the Health Services Under
extraordinary pressure right now and
some people watching this this afternoon
might say is that it how soon will
things improve in the NHS this winter
thanks Chris look as I acknowledge right
at the beginning of the speech I think
that's the thing that people are most
worried about and it's why when I talked
about my five priorities the five
promises that I made to the country
making sure that we reduce waiting times
in the NHS was one of them it's
something I've been working on a lot
since I was pm and that's why I want the
country to hold me account for
delivering it now there are lots of
things we are doing this winter for
example the most acute pressure we have
is in a e and we can see that so what I
want the country to know is there are a
range of things we're doing that will
make a difference the the biggest
problem we have is that there are the
moment around 13 000 people in hospital
beds who ideally should be back in their
communities or in Social care and that's
what's making sure our hospitals full
and that's what's slowing the the flow
of people from ambulances into a e and
through so what are we doing to address
that well we've put half a billion
pounds into what's called early
discharge to help move people into the
communities this winter we're rolling
out something called virtual Awards
which are where people for example who
have acute respiratory infections can
actually be treated at home with
telemedicine or pulse oximeters which
will free up capacity in the NHS we're
rolling out a new fall service so that
we can save about 55 000 ambulance call
outs a year by treating people with
Falls at home and we need to do a better
job on preventative medicine so many
people with undiagnosed high blood
pressure who end up ultimately having a
cardiac issue that requires an ambulance
call out so those are just some of the
things that we're doing this winter that
I am confident will make a difference we
also have a plan in place to get NHS
waiting times when it comes to elective
surgery down and that's something that
I'm confident we can do and we will you
know buy I I believe in just a few
months of practically eliminated waiting
times for those waiting a year and a
half we've already eliminated those
waiting two years and by next spring I
think we'll have eliminated those
waiting a year and that's because we've
got a clear plan in place but what I
want the country to know is this is an
absolute priority for me I made five
promises today and making sure that
people can get the care that they need
as quickly as they need it is right
there as one of those priorities the
country should hold me to account for
delivering it and I'm confident that we
will
next Carl Dinan from ITV
thank you prime minister
um just on that point about having fewer
people in hospital and not more
paramedics tell us that you might even
have to consider pausing elective
procedures in order to allow them to get
people in the front door as it were of
hospitals isn't this the wrong time to
be concentrating on waiting lists when
there are queues of ambulances trying to
get people who need Urgent Care into
Hospital
we'll call the simple answers we need to
do both
right and you heard my answer to Chris
there's a range of things we're doing
that are going to make the most
difference in the short term to a e and
Urgent Care and as I said the most the
most impressing priority we have is is
to move people into social care with the
communities that will mean that we can
actually get ambulances flowing as fast
as we would like and make sure that
people are moving into a e as quickly as
we would like them to be seen but your
point on electives actually highlights
the issue that's what we shouldn't do
right and that's what happened during
covid we stopped doing elective surgery
right the amount of elective activity in
the NHS was down to about half of what
it normally does so the reason we've got
a huge waiting list now is because we're
having to catch up with that and
actually one of our initiatives to stop
that from happening again is to create
what are called elective surgical hubs
and Community diagnostic Centers where
people can get all the scans and the
tests they need and indeed the elective
routine elective surgery like hip
replacements and cataracts away from the
acute part of a hospital because if you
do that what you do is really increase
our ability to treat people because you
don't have doctors constantly disrupted
by doing routine appointments and then
having to rush to deal with an emergency
that's the model that works really well
we're rolling out 300 Community
diagnostic Centers and elective surgical
hubs across the country and that will
allow us to do both it will allow us to
treat our parents grandparents that are
waiting for one of those surgeries that
they need but it will also allow us to
treat people in hospitals who need that
urgent care so you know my priority is
to do both and I think the plans we've
got in place we'll deliver it and that's
why we put more funding into the NHS it
can't forget that just a couple of
months ago the Autumn statement we had
to make some very difficult decisions as
a government to get our debt under
control to make sure that we control
inflation but in spite of all of those
things we put extra money into the NHS
and social care 14 billion pounds over
the next two years now we need to make
sure that we deliver that money in the
way that I've described so that people
feel the benefit in the care that they
and their families receive and we've got
a clear plan to do it my job is to
deliver it and then I want people to
hold me for account for it that's one of
some of the five promises I made today
Rigby from Skye
Rigby from Skye thank you um prime
minister look we know to expect to
reassurance uh performance from you but
in the real world you can't get a train
you can't get a doctor's appointment
nurses are going to food banks and when
you do dial 999 you can't be sure that
an ambulance is going to get there in
time to save your loved one that's the
reality of Britain in 2023 and now
you're here giving people more promises
about how you might change the country
that they've heard many times before
during 13 years of conservative rule my
question really is why should the public
believe you any different to any of your
predecessors
I think the country have seen me
performing the job before through really
difficult times they saw me as
Chancellor during covid in fact most of
them probably didn't know who I was
until I appeared on that press
conference on their TV screens and I'm
proud of the record that I have as
Chancellor I think we moved at enormous
speed and with competence to actually
deliver interventions that made a
difference to people's lives that saved
their jobs Protected Their businesses
and so people can trust that when I say
I'm going to do something I am going to
do it and the second thing is I've been
very clear as I said today unambiguous
made five very simple promises the
country's priorities are my priorities I
want to be held account for them there's
no ambiguity about them there's no
tricks people will know whether I'm
delivering on these things and I'm
confident that we can I really am and
you talk about the record you know
actually I'm not going to say the NHS
wasn't under any pressure before covert
of course it was but that you know there
were places where things were really
improving and you look at ambulance
times for example category to we are
just about at Target before covid hit
and it's undeniable though that kovid
has had an impact I talked about the
fact that elective surgery was paused
during covert you can look at the same
with cancer referrals they were down by
a third or two-thirds during covid and
now obviously there are far more than
normal right so that's why that's not
performing as well as we would like it
to but it's improving so look covert has
had an impact it's not an excuse this is
one of my five promises people know what
I did for them during covert as
Chancellor and that's why I'm here today
being very clear about what I'm going to
deliver for them in the country as prime
minister I'm very confident we can do
that but ultimately people will hold me
to account for doing so
right Olivia Utley from GB news
to improve
so I I was very clear about the
importance of family to me and actually
I think it's good that we talk about
family because it's a wonderful thing
that we should talk about more and I
specifically talked about part of modern
families today is making sure that we
can balance between work life and and
family life and childcare is obviously
an important part of that the government
and I am completely committed to
ensuring good availability and
affordability and flexibility of child
care that's what we're always looking to
deliver and improve on the offers that
we have there's a consultation that is
out at the moment and we're in the
process considering about some reforms
and it wouldn't be right for me to
comment on that now but the fact that
I've spent time talking about family
hopefully gives you and everyone some
confidence that it is important to me
and we want to make sure that we support
families in all their forms to have
happy fulfilling lives that are filled
with love and nurturing for their
children in the same way that I was
fortunate to benefit from
Gary Gibbon from Channel 4 News
thank you prime minister
um can I just uh in the interest of
clearing up any ambiguity clarify which
of these pledges are for this year
um halving inflation this year you said
in line with most forecasts including
the APR what about the others growing
the economy this year
NHS waiting list falling this year
you said new laws to stop small boats
well maybe you could do that this year
but would you stop small boats this year
and could I ask another question over
recent months years actually Britain's
often been
compared with Italy and the political
and economic crises that happened there
they've occasionally had to restore calm
a technocrat
who's taken over are you out technocrat
it's Gary on on the five the five
promises I made let me just inflation
the plan is very much and the my
expectation is that we will be at a half
the rate of inflation by the end of this
year uh on our path by the way to
restoring inflation back to where it
belongs which is two percent inflation
Target that we set the bank of England
you know that I'm Keen to deliver on the
plans that we've set out that we'll see
inflation halving as I said by the end
of this year and at the same time I'd
like the economy to be growing by then
as well so those two goals are both for
this year in terms of debt falling we
already have got plans in place to make
sure that debt does fall in the medium
term the key is sticking to those and
making sure we have the discipline uh to
do so because that's not always easy but
it's the right thing to do to secure the
future of public services and indeed to
combat inflation and then regard to NHS
waiting times so last year we
practically eliminated people waiting
over two years because of the plans that
we've put in place that increase the
amount of elective activity we have that
I talked a little bit about uh we will
you know we are on track to eliminate
the weights for one and a half years
practically by about April of this year
and by Spring of next year we will have
practically have eliminated those
waiting over a year with the overall
waiting list falling and then lastly
we're keen to introduce legislation as
soon as practically possible ultimately
Parliament uh decides how long it takes
to pass that legislation
um but in all of these things look I you
know I've deliberately not put a
specific month on on each of them
because I don't think that's responsible
or or the right thing to do with with
goals that are so complicated where many
of the forces that will impact our
ability to hit them are out of my
control as well right then we've seen
that over the past year or two but what
I am being very clear about is what I am
prioritizing what I am Keen to deliver
for the country in terms that I think
are easy to understand and unambiguous I
fully expect the country to hold me and
the government to account for how much
effort we're putting in to working on
those priorities to their priorities and
then ultimately you know how and when we
deliver them but that's why I'm being
crystal clear about what we're doing and
why
in the interest of time actually I think
well hopefully you can digest the speech
in in longer time but I think the
country at the moment has a very clear
set of priorities that they want their
government to focus on those are the
five promises I made it's about halving
inflation growing the economy reducing
debt cutting waiting times and stopping
the boats those are our five immediate
priorities but also today I sketched out
the better future for our children and
the grandchildren that I want to create
that is not the work of as I said one
year or one Parliament but that is the
journey that I want our country to go on
and I'm really confident that we can
make good progress on that as well in
the interest of trying to get as many of
your colleagues in as possible I'll ask
people just to limit themselves to one
question if that's okay going forward
um Ben Riley Smith from the telegraph
thank you prime minister one question
with an A and A B if that's all right
your plan for growth uh you said you
wanted to reduce the tax burden I know
you're not going to set the spring
budget here but How likely do you think
it is you might be able to reduce the
tax burden with the spring budget and
also you talked about getting people
back into work can you give me one
specific policy idea a new policy idea
you're looking at to do that well I
think Ben on both of those you know I'm
not I'm not going to preempt what the
chancellor does in the spring budget I
certainly preferred it when I had his
job when the Prime Minister didn't do
that and I'll try and uh I'll try and
stick by that
um but look well I'd repeat what I said
in the speech I I think work is really
important it's important not just
because it provides Financial Security
of course it does that for for us and
our families but I think work provides
people with purpose providing with
dignity and confidence it's something to
be celebrated and rewarded which is why
as soon as we are able to I want to cut
taxes on working people that's something
that I think the chancellor is also
aligned on but right now we've got a set
of challenges that we're grappling with
and that's a priority as I am as I've
outlined and and with regard to
inactivity that there's a range of
things that we are looking at that the
chancellor in the work and pension
sector are working on together and
there's again with all of these things
there's no one thing that will make the
difference there's probably a range of
things but as I mentioned in the speech
you know we need to look at how our
welfare system is operating and is it
operating in the way that we would like
to make sure that we are supporting
incentivizing people who can be to be in
work and you know that's the work that
we've started some of but clearly
there's lots of options that we can look
at there and that's why I mentioned it
specifically and but as I said the
budget is a time for these types of
things and the chance we'll make those
uh announcements in in due course
uh Steve swimford from the times
prime minister you've said that you want
to stop the boats can I ask what exactly
do you mean by that do you mean but by
the time the next election there will be
no Small Boat Crossings or do you mean
that there will just be fewer Small Boat
Crossings just to get some definition
around that key delivery Target of yours
yeah so Steve I think I'll do that the
country will judge as I said right the
country will be the judge of whether we
as a government are straining everything
you to focus on their priorities and
deliver meaningful progress and change
on them now when I when I made a
statement in Parliament last month about
small boats I you know I went out of my
way to say that this is not an easy
problem to fix right and it's not one
that we can fix overnight and it
requires lots of different things to be
changed now we've made progress on that
already the new deal with France means
that there's 40 more patrols happening
in France which is making a difference
to us then you deal with Albania will
enable us to return more illegal
migrants who have come here from that
country back to where uh they're from
you know they accounted for a third of
all Small Boat Crossings uh in the
latter part of last year so that could
make a really big difference but the
most important thing we need to do is
pass new legislation and we want to make
sure that that new legislation means
that if you come here illegally to our
country you will not be able to stay you
will be detained and swiftly removed
back to a safe country or
um your own home if that's appropriate
that's the type of system that I think
makes
sense I think it's enormous or only
common sense I think everyone watching
will think that's the type of systems we
should have but as we've seen already
with our Rwanda policy there are plenty
of people who will try and stop that
from happening but what I want to make
sure that the country knows is I'm
working day and night to deliver that
system and the next step on that journey
is to introduce new laws that will allow
us to put that system in place but that
is not going to happen overnight but
that is what people will see us working
very hard on uh in the coming weeks and
months
Jason Groves from the mail
thanks Kim
um don't you have to resolve the strikes
that are going on if you're going to get
peace of mind and get the growth that
you want and how are you going to do
that without paying people more do you
think you can legislate your way out of
this problem
well thanks Jason look on strikes I
really want to make sure the country and
everyone understands the government's
position and that is that we hugely
respect and value the work done by our
public sector workers across the board
but obviously nurses are a part of that
as well and a special part of that and I
also want everyone to know that we're
very keen on dialogue the government's
door is always open the transport
secretary store the health secretary's
door they were very keen to have
constructive two-way dialogue that's
honest that's open where we can talk
about the challenges everyone's facing
and see what we can all do to find a
resolution to these strikes you know
I've always I've always been clear about
that I wanted to reiterate that today
now you know I've said in this that
you'll hear more from the government in
the coming days about our approach but
my view is you know people should always
behave reasonably and fairly and make
sure that what we're doing is centered
around what's responsible for the
country what's affordable for the
country and I think that's the right
dialogue to be having well I hope we can
have that done log but I've also said
much as I I celebrate and value the work
of unions in our society they play an
important role and people should have
the right to strike that has to be
balanced with the right of the British
public to be able to go about their
lives without suffering completely
undue disruption in the way that we've
seen recently and that's why I said we
will introduce a new legislation that
restores that balance and crucially
protects people's lives as well as their
livelihoods but you'll hear more more
from the government in the coming days
on that
Ryan seby the Sun
prime minister you recently said that
you had two years to turn things around
today you say judge me if you don't get
your priorities right and get things
done will the public have every right to
send you packing
well Ryan I I I I you know the British
public will make their decision right
like my job is to deliver for them right
and my job is to deliver for them on
their priorities you know I believe the
country has five priorities that's why
I've made five promises today five very
simple things that everyone can
understand half inflation grow the
economy reduce debt cut waiting lists
and stop the boats five promises that I
have made five things that my government
will focus relentlessly on to make a
difference to people's lives but also
those things are the foundation of the
better future that I want to create for
our children and grandchildren right
they're not the end of my ambition
they're the start of my ambition and
that's why today I sketched out what
that better future looks like and
although we're not going to get there
overnight and the things that I talked
about are the immediate priorities for
us to deliver I'm confident we can make
progress towards that better future as
well and I'm not focused on the politics
I'm not focused on anything else I'm
just focused on delivering on the things
I think are important to people and
that's what I get up to do every day and
that's what the rest of the government
does as well
George Parker at the ft
thank you prime minister
um you said at the outset that you
wanted to bring peace of mind
um I think you're probably aware that in
one area at least you're creating more
uncertainty and distress and that's in
the area of revoking or repealing up to
4 000 pieces of EU legislation by the
end of the year 12 organizations from
the TUC to The Institute of directors
pleaded with you last year to abandon
the end of 2023 deadline why don't you
give them that Assurance today that
there won't be this huge upheaval at the
end of the year
well Georgian in my speech I talked
about the future economy that we need to
build right and it's an economy that's
built on Innovation that is the best way
for us to raise our growth rate which is
something I know everybody wants to see
and a big part of that is making sure
that we do seize the opportunities of
brexit and make sure that our
regulations are agile that they support
Innovation and do so particularly in the
growth industries of the future and
that's why the chancellors talked about
delivering exactly that whether it's in
AI whether it's in Quantum whether it's
in life sciences or fintech and I think
that's really important and we are going
to deliver that and if we do you know
that's how we create jobs in every part
of our country that's how we make sure
people's living standards rise is how we
spread prosperity it's how we are
competitive around the world so it's an
important part of delivering on making
sure that the UK is the most Innovative
place in the world and we have new
opportunities and freedoms to do that
and we are absolutely going to seize
them to deliver for the country
hypocrite from the guardian
Mr Prime Minister you say you see the
nurses and NHS staff are special all the
pub all the polls tell us that the
public overwhelmingly agrees but also
that they support the strike action
being taken by nurses and Hospital
workers you also say you can on dialogue
with the unions so can you explain why
you aren't willing to negotiate their
pay and would you look again at nurses
pensions bonuses and holiday pay instead
and finally can you rule out raising NHS
staff salaries by just two percent next
year as you're reportedly planning thank
you so so people of course the NHS is is
special right it's special to me because
of the family that I grew up in but it's
special to all of us because of the care
it provides us at times when we really
need it and and I'm really grateful to
our nurses and everyone else in the NHS
for the incredible job they do
particularly over the last couple of
years which has been trying for them
because of covid when it comes to
dialogue I'd repeat what I've said
before the door is always open for
dialogue the health secretary was out
this morning talking to healthcare
workers the rail minister is sitting
down with transport unions uh early next
week and you know we're always as I said
previously that we want to have good
two-way open honors conversations those
have to be rooted in what's reasonable
what's affordable what's responsible for
the country and you know I'm Keen to
have those conversations there's lots of
things that we can talk about and you
know I'm I'm hopeful well as I said on
page as conversations need to be based
on what is Affordable I think a 19 pay
rise is is not affordable I don't think
anyone thinks that a 19 pay rise is
Affordable but that doesn't mean we
shouldn't have dialogue that we
shouldn't have conversations you talked
about next year we're about to start a
new process for pay for this year that's
exactly the kind of thing that we should
be sitting down and talking to the
unions about before everyone submits
evidence to that independent process to
understand where we're all coming from
and as I say we'll be setting out uh you
know more more of our plans in this
Regard in the coming days
McCann talk TV
thank you prime minister you've made
five promises today but your
predecessors also made a promise a big
one to reform social care and you were
part of the government that were
supposed to deliver on that they've rode
back you are accused of doing the same
now you've just accepted that one of the
biggest challenges the NHS faces is
social care and you've also promised big
thinking and no quick fixes but there's
still no plan to deal with the social
care problem so how can people trust you
to deliver on five more pledges today
when you're yet to deliver on this one
and will you resign if you don't
so Kate when you talk about social care
literally just announced billions of
pounds more funding for social care uh
on on top of the money that I announced
as as Chancellor so I don't think anyone
can say that we're not prioritizing
social care it's never had more
investment and the reason it's so
important is because not only do people
deserve and need high quality social
care but it is the cause of many of the
delays that we're seeing in our Urgent
Care departments and RNA any departments
and with ambulances because as I said
we've got 13 000 people occupying
hospital beds that ideally should be
back in their communities or in Social
care settings so it's a big part of how
we actually improve emergency wait times
that's why we've prioritized it and
that's why we have a discharge fund for
this winter particularly to do exactly
that it's why we're investing in the
social care Workforce something that
they've cried out for rightly for years
so and now we're doing it we're
introducing a sense of career
progression for the first time high
quality certification and qualifications
and training all the the things that
were not there previously that have led
to some of the the kind of high or the
low retention rates you've seen in the
sector the vacancies a big part of the
reason for that is people not feeling
valued and that's more than just about
how much they're paid it's about all
those other things I talked about the
investment we're putting in is going to
deliver that and people are going to see
that change
um but what you're talking about I think
is something slightly different which is
about the caps on care you know that has
been delayed yes because right now we
have got an enormous priority as we're
all seeing on our TV screens and it's
important that we fix that priority and
as actually many in local government
called on us to do was to delay those
reforms so that we could focus that same
money which by the way is still going
into social care but is now being used
to deal with the immediate pressures
that we're facing that's the right thing
to do I think everyone agrees that
that's the right thing to do because we
can't do everything and right now
actually just creating more social care
capacity making sure that our social
care workers are properly valued have
the respect they deserve the career
progression that they want those are the
right priorities not only if we do that
will we improve social care in this
country will also improve the experience
people are having currently with
ambulances and a e and I'm confident
that we can make progress on that
Andy Bell channel five
thanks prime minister
um
to all those people who are worried
about the state of the NHS to all those
people working in the NHS who wonder if
it can keep going are you really saying
there's no more money you've had what
you're getting it's been announced there
isn't going to be any more now you get
on with it is that what you're saying in
effect to them
well you know Andy I'm saying a couple
of things first of all thank you for the
incredible job they do and I know that
over the past two years we all know that
and also I grew up in an NHS family so I
know how important high quality
Healthcare is to people I saw my parents
doing it day in day out for for decades
uh and with regard to resources it's
right that we fund the NHS well and we
are and that's why in spite of the
difficult decisions we have to make
elsewhere we have found extra money for
the NHS and social care and I think that
was recognized by many independent
people at the time of the Autumn
statement that we had prioritized the
NHS that we had listened and put more
funding in now a conversation of you
know how that funding is split up and
how much should be on pay versus
actually having more nurses or how much
it should be going on more diagnostic
equipment right those are the decisions
that we're and the NHS are making that's
why we have an independent process on
pay rightly that the RCN I think were
one of the people they called for in the
80s that there should be a independent
pay review body process and the
government has respected those decisions
those are independent processes they
make recommendations to the government
in many cases higher and what higher
than what the government initially
suggested and higher than what many
people in the private sector are
receiving but accepted them in full
because that's the right thing to do but
as I said previously to Beth and others
and to Pippa we're always happy to have
a dialogue the door is always open we're
talking about the process for next year
that's exactly the kind of thing we
should be sitting down and talking
through and it's not just about pay I'm
sure you know when you're out about
talking to whether it's ambulance
workers or others you know there's
things about how their job is working
that you know they would like to see
improved right and that's some of the
things that we did with nurses in the
past they wanted to see more
support for their professional
development you know what we instituted
a 1 000 pound training budget something
the RCN really wanted us to do it wasn't
about pay it was about supporting nurses
once they qualified to be upskilled to
learn more and to train more so we put a
thousand pound training budget for every
nurse and midwife right they wanted
nurses bursaries reintroduced we
delivered that too it's 5 000 pounds a
year for a nurse that's in training
right so there's lots of things that are
not necessarily paid that are also
important and we should be talking about
all these things and the door is always
open to talk about them
Martin Brown the express
thank you prime minister you said at the
end of your speech you'll you'll make
the
um tough calls and going back to the
small boat crisis will you um as part of
your plans will you introduce similar
schemes to the Albanian fast deportation
scheme and also could we expect another
offshore uh processing center like
Rwanda
awesome well so with Rwanda first of all
I'm really pleased that we had the Court
ruling that we had which made it clear
that Rwanda is a safe country that it is
completely fine for us to be able to
send people there to have their claims
process and indeed that that's in
keeping with a refugee convention and
other International treaties that we are
a signatory to you know we need to make
sure that that policy works it's an
important part of our plan to tackle the
small boats that we're seeing
um in terms of what more we can do
vis-a-vis Albania Albania in one sense
was a special case because it accounted
that one country accounted for a third
of all small boat arrivals at one point
uh last year so and it's and it's
clearly a safe country it's a country
where France Belgium many others Germany
Scandinavian countries all return 98 of
illegal Asylum Seekers we were only
rejecting 45 percent that clearly isn't
right and our new deal and our new
changes in process will move us into
alignment with other countries more
generally we do need to look at one of
the things I mentioned at the time of
the announcement was returns agreements
you know where we have people who are
here who shouldn't be here you know we
need to make sure that the returns
agreements we have with countries are
working and you know we we've taken
powers in legislation that we passed
earlier this year to impose Visa
penalties where that makes sense on
countries that are not cooperating in
receiving back failed Asylum Seekers
from us and that should be a part of the
conversations we're having with
countries around the world and we're
seeing good progress on those and that's
one of the parts of the plan that we
need to deliver on as well you know
working and functioning returns
agreements so that's that will be a bit
of a focus for next as well but you know
it's deliberately one of the five
promises I made today I think it's a top
priority for the country I think people
saw that I'd spent time on it and come
up with a a clear and sensible way to
make progress on it last month and the
job for this year is to keep making
progress and deliver on that
Martina bertetto from PA oh do you know
you
thank you prime minister
um you want to introduce new laws to
stop illegal migration but why is more
legislation necessary given the
nationality and borders Act was recently
passed it is an admission that the laws
passed by the previous story government
have failed to do what was promised
so Martina I just want to make sure that
we fix this problem and having had this
job for a few weeks and spent time
thinking about it you know my belief is
that we do need new laws if we want to
actually comprehensively deal with this
challenge the system that I want to
deliver is one whereby if someone comes
to our country illegally they won't have
the right to stay they can be detained
and sent back to their own home or a
safe alternative if their own home isn't
appropriate I think that's a common
sense system I think it's a reasonable
and fair system and that's what we need
legislation to deliver and that's the
legislation that we will introduce in
due course but it's one of my five
promises for a reason as I said it's an
incredibly important priority for the
country it's an important priority for
me and as I think hopefully people have
already seen we've begun to deliver on
it and there'll be more to come this
year
brilliant well thank you very much all
for your time it's been a great pleasure
and have a good 2023.
[Applause]
of
2023 where she's doing that making five
promises to the public setting out his
government's priorities for the year
ahead say we will halve inflation grow
the economy reduce debt cut waiting
lists and stop the boats he said they
are the Public's priorities therefore
they are also the governments let's
bring in our political correspondent Liz
Bates who was following that speech and
the resulting question and answer
session uh afterwards which lasted for
over an hour um over half an hour uh Liz
um the one criticism that we could see
coming from the off from that speech is
there were five big promises very little
detail
yes I think and that's that is fair
um to say I thought one of the things
that was interesting about it and you're
completely right
um it did go on for quite a long time so
there's lots to look at and assess in
that and I think particularly from the
perspective of looking at it as the
starting gun to a general election this
is the Rishi sunak that we are going to
see on the general election trail and I
think there are a few interesting
aspects to note first of all uh in his
performance I mean he was this is the
first time I think we've seen him that